how bad can it get
will we see a ten percent official
number or will they manipulate it and
pull stuff out make sure we don't that's
a good question well so look if we stay
at this pace we will see a 10 official
number in a matter of months and that's
the problem and so the problem we see it
next month given how fast oil has
exploded upwards and some of these other
commodities yeah i mean you could well
you mean yeah we could see it in march
is yeah yeah the march number could come
in at ten percent you're absolutely
right so the february number again we're
talking about february inflation prints
the energy inflation was uh annualized
at 51 percent
and so that probably is going to double
in march and so we could very much see
something that looks like 10 percent
inflation so
again that i mean the the the fed is
their toast i mean they
whatever financial stability mandate
they have or whatever inclination you
might have thought as an investor that
they're going to protect risk assets or
protect growth protect the economy i
think you have to throw those out the
window and the sooner you throw them out
the window the more likely it is you're
going to not lose a lot of money joe
biden says that uh the february
inflation numbers uh prove the cost of
sanctions but the sanctions didn't
happen until like the last three days in
february in march uh what do you think
about that oh my god don't get me
started with the politicians now it's
like oh well it's all sanctions in the
russian war and ukraine like these are
february data points
you know like what are you talking about
inflation couldn't tell the future yeah
i know
no i know dude
but look they this is the problem with
politicians right they are still living
in the newspaper radio era where they
think we're all uneducated and
uninformed but obviously thanks to
programs like this programs you know
services like mine and just general
knowledge and on the internet
to begin with we're not as dumb as they
think we are people are pissed off i
think there's a serious sight guys i can
see it in all the statistics consumer
confidence is rancid right now and we're
we're talking about economy that is you
know most recent gdp print is the seven
percent growing economy it's you know
three times our our potential growth
rate and people are pissed off what
happens when they're pissed off and we
slow back to trend or below trend you
know as we as our models project for the
you know in the second half of this year
and so
this is a big problem i don't see how we
get out of this very easily and
sometimes there's not always an easy
answer right if they raise interest
rates is it pretty much a guarantee
we'll go into a recession uh i think
it's a guarantee we're going to
recession regardless i mean you've done
enough damage to consumer confidence to
real incomes um that we're probably
going to go into recession regardless
and this is something i said a few weeks
ago remember we're we're probably gonna
we're gonna have two choices as
investors and really the fed has two
choices
allow the economy to go into recession
because inflation destroys will incomes
and confidence enough to cause a decline
in in purchasing power and ultimately
decline in the you know the quantity of
goods and services that are purchased or
do you send the economy into a recession
because you're get you know you're
clawing back some of the credibility you
lost on the inflation and price
stability front i happen to think the
fed is more likely to choose scenario b
over scenario a because scenario a is
that's kind of the death nail for the
central bank you know if your whole you
know if you're here to prevent things
like recessions and financial crises you
know if you if you can't prevent that
you lose your entire credibility
whatsoever and i don't think the fed is
willing to risk that at least it's not
my indication they haven't given us any
indication that they're willing to risk
that as we head into a recession what do
you think will actually play out in
terms of uh risk assets like tech stocks
etc i've already sold off a lot is there
still like 50 more to go what do you
think of other types of assets as well
yeah that's a great question so let me
be clear like recession we're nowhere
near a recession now you know this
economy's still growing well above
potential the problem is the speed of
the decline from growing well above
potential to growing something that's
below trend is accelerating you know
we've already had that as a pretty
pretty sharp d cell starting in the you
know kind of middle this part of this
year but that pretty sharp d sale could
actually it looks like it's going to be
faster now and so um as it relates to
asset prices you know it seems like
we're only that i hate to use the word
seems like but you know there's really
not too many
perfect corollaries to what we're
experiencing i mean you can sort of cite
the 1970s um as it relates to to you
know you know the
response of asset markets to what we're
experiencing today i happen to think
where we are today is somewhere between
it's a hybrid between the 2000 and 2002
unwind of the tech bubble and the 2018
experience where the fed was sort of
tightening tightening tightening and
didn't realize the economy was slowing
and ultimately the markets had to tell
the fed to back off and i think you
merged that experience you know q418
with kind of the unwind of that the tech
bubble and i think that's where we are
today hey you did you like this video
great we make five of them a day and
post them here on this channel make sure
you subscribe like the video and see you
next time